joining Rossi and I at the desk a dad
who named his son Drake because of the
rapper actually it's actor Adam
[Applause]
yes that's really that's really how we
named Ricky we every time we we have a
child which is not like that many times
but we we uh how many children do you
have three which is like that's a lot I
guess it is a couple many times yeah but
uh we we pick names based on like we try
to roast the name as best we can so that
we anticipate all the things they'll be
called in school uh-huh good and Drake
just felt like I don't think there's ma
like it felt foolproof yeah snake pretty
good but I know by the way not bad break
the snake that sounds like a wrestler
yeah
I like that you're naming kids after
your favorite performers my daughter
Beyonce is going to love this yeah I
have to tell you well well she'll get
along great with my other son
um Steven Spielberg
it'll be a party yes all three of my
kids have like New York uh like cool
names Drake Drake George Grace oh and
Cole oh good name fantastic you're a
good dad oh thank you uh that's the only
thing I know
all right we are at the news desk Adam
will you get into some news with us of
course
okay
up first people reports that Anna
Sorokin aka Anna delvey aka the inspo
for Netflix inventing Anna is getting
her own reality show called delvey's
Dinner Party The not German air SS is
currently under a house arrest after
being found guilty on eight charges so
the show will feature people of Note
coming to her New York apartment for
dinner and intimate conversations you
mean inmate conversations
all right that's taboo wasn't she in
June she was no that's right I think we
can make fun of that yeah
Drew Ross would you attend this dinner
party oh my God I would so attend a
sitter party I would show up early and I
would stay late and I would talk like
this the entire time and I didn't tell
me VIP is better I watch every single
second did you watch inventing Anna uh I
didn't but that doesn't mean anything
because I I haven't seen any show ever
well you have the most recent show you
binged
uh Severance maybe oh that's a good one
you do after watching venting Anna
though it's so you guys watching venting
Anna did you watch the video it was
Netflix fun hilarious twisted and real
is there anything you watch that you're
embarrassed about like I talk about here
that I watch 90 Day Fiance all the time
like at least like 20 hours is there
anything you watch for like I cannot
believe I love Real Housewives and and
below deck is really funny
[Applause]
perfect like perfect covid viewing
really yes like if you have a case of
covid that like is taking you out for a
little bit throw on all of below debt
okay yeah when I had coveted I watched
all of House of dragon and all of the
crown what does that say about me
right it's two very different like
similar tone but different times yes yes
but all a bit heavy but all a bit
delicious yeah well next up Insider says
all the single ladies well they're at
Home Depot get this women on Tick Tock
are deleting their dating apps and
heading down the lumber aisle looking
for love I mean I guess I'm not the only
one who's hot for romance Adam you're
married but you may have you know single
male friends or any of them at Home
Depot uh not Home Depot but they do this
at other places like Macaroni Grill yeah
and a Best Buy they'll walk in there
um and go yeah and go a hunting they'll
just be like lost and looking around and
be like I need this plug
hey well I get it I think you know
making it makes sense you go to Home
Depot instead of going to like a bar you
can still you'll get hammered
go get it that's fun so go ahead all
right lastly Time Magazine brings us a
Pew research study that says 90 of
American parents want their kids to be
financially independent while only 10
percent say it's important for them to
get married and start a family but I
think 100 said just get out of the house
just get out but isn't that interesting
that 90 they are focused on making sure
they're financially stable as a parent
do you worry about that
um I would definitely worry about that
more than them being married and having
a family I I don't I I think the number
one concern I just want my kids to be
like okay like at the base level like
you know like that deserves no touch
yeah thank you a pet what's happening
um but yeah no I think like you don't
even think about like like I don't even
think about do I want them to be rich or
married I just like just I want to make
sure that they can like
be okay you know when I'm not there okay
you know what I mean like yeah safe and
manners yeah yeah those are the two
things yeah I just want them to be able
to like make their way and not let
things throw them off you know like oh
that's I think about that way more than
like God I hope they'll be financially
independent you know what I mean because
like that most likely they they won't
I mean just judging from their
handwriting okay
we're not done yet up next Adam weighs
in on vasectomies we have I have I found
this story you guys have gotta hear it
it's insane we'll be right back
[Music]